There are three main types of chocolate:...
...dark chocolate, milk chocolate and white chocolate.
Chocolate liquor and cocoa butter are the two ingredients used to make chocolate...
...that are derived from the cocoa seed or bean.
Cocoa butter is the natural fat from the cocoa bean...
...and it enhances flavor and mouthfeel.
It is the only ingredient from the cocoa bean used to make white chocolate.
Other types of chocolate are made from cocoa butter...
...plus another ingredient made from the cocoa bean called chocolate liquor.
This is the term for cocoa beans with their shells removed...
...that have been roasted and ground until they liquefy.